.
WELCOME TO "CONNECT THE WORLD."
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
AIR STRIKES ON GAZA, ROCKETS
FIRED TOWARD ISRAEL AND HUNDREDS
REPORTEDLY KILLED.
IMMEASURABLE DESTRUCTION.
THE CONFLICT MOVED INTO A SECOND
WEEK WITH THESE ALL TOO FAMILIAR
SCENES AND NO END IN SIGHT.
THIS WEEK BEGAN WITH EVEN MORE
BLOOD SHED.
52 PEOPLE IN GAZA WERE KILLED
SUNDAY.
THAT'S THE MOST IN A SINGLE DAY
IN THE CURRENT FLARE UP SO FAR
BRINGING THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
DEATHS TO 200.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO THE MINISTRY
THERE.
FIGHTER JETS HIT THE HOMES OF
TOP BUILDINGS.
THEY WERE PART OF A TERROR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
PALESTINIAN MILITANTS FIRED
ROCKETS AT SEVERAL ISRAELI
TOWNS.
TEN ISRAELIS HAVE BEEN KILLED IN
THE PAST WEEK.
THE U.N. SECURITY COUNCIL HELD
AN EMERGENCY MEETING SUNDAY IN
WHICH THE ISRAELI AND
PALESTINIAN REPRESENTATIVES
ACCUSED EACH OTHER OF COMMITTING
WAR CRIMES.
SECRETARY GENERAL OF THE U.N.
PLEADED FOR CEASE-FIRE BUT THAT
APPEARS UNLIKELY TO HAPPEN ANY
TIME SOON.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT ISRAEL
EASE PRIME MINISTER HAD TO SAY.
>> WE'LL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES TO
RESTORE ORDER AND QUIET AND ON
THE SECURITY OF OUR PEOPLE.
WE'RE TRYING TO DEGRADE HAMAS
TERRORIST ABILITY AND DEGRADE
THEIR WILL TO DO THIS AGAIN.
IT WILL TAKE SOME TIME.
I HOPE IT WON'T TAKE LONG BUT
IT'S NOT IMMEDIATE.
>> THE VARIOUS ASPECTS OF THIS
CON
CONFLICT.
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THE ANGER
GROWING ACROSS THE REGION AND
THE WORLD.
WE WILL CONNECT YOU TO THE WHITE
HOUSE WHERE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
IS UNDER INCREASING PRESSURE.
BEN, AS WE HAVE BEEN SEEING,
SUNDAY, WAS THE DEADLIEST DAY SO
FAR SINCE THIS CONFLICT BEGAN A
WEEK AGO.
THE STRIKES CONTINUE OVERNIGHT.
ISRAEL IS TARGETING HAMAS
TUNNELS IN GAZA.
>> Reporter: IT CALLS THOSE
TUNNELS THE SO CALLED METRO, AN
EXTENSIVE SYSTEM OF TUNNELS THAT
ALLOWS HAMAS FIGHTERS AND
OFFICIALS THE MOVE OUT OF THE
VIEW OF ISRAELI DRONES, AIRPLANE
AND OTHER MEANS OF SURVEILLANCE.
THEY SAY THEY HAVE DESTROYED
UNTIL NOW ABOUT 100 KILOMETERS
OF THOSE TUNNELS.
THE GROUND INCURSION AT THIS
POINT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
IMMINENT DESPITE RECENT TWEETS
BY THE ISRAELI MILITARY.
THE RULESULT OF AIR STRIKES TO E
GAZA STRIP.
THEY ARE HOPING THOSE ARE SITES
THAT WILL NOT BE HIT BY ISRAELI
AIR STRIKES.
THE HUMANITARIAN SITUATION
CONTINUES TO DETERIORATE
DRAMATICALLY.
WE SOMETIMES FORGET THERE'S A
COVID PANDEMIC GOING ON.
WE SPOKE TO A REPRESENTATIVE WHO
SAID AS MANY AS 30% OF THE
POPULATION IN GAZA HAS BEEN OR
IS INFECTED BY COVID.
OBVIOUSLY, ANY ATTEMPT TO
VACCINATE THE POPULATION OR TEST
THE POPULATION HAS BEEN CRIPPLED
BY THE ONGOING HOSTILITIES FOR A
PLACE WHICH A FEW YEARS AGO A
SENIOR UC.N. OFFICIAL SAID GAZA
IS A TOXIC SLUM.
>> JUST TALK TO US ABOUT THE
TACTICS ISRAEL IS USING RIGHT
NOW WHERE ITS AIR STRIKES
BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING ENTIRE
BUILDINGS COLLAPSE ING INCLUDIN
ONE THAT HOUSES THE BUREAUS OF
INTERNATIONAL MEETINGS.
WE KNOW ISRAEL HAS THE ABILITY
TO PINPOINT ITS ATTACKS.
WHY ARE WE SEEING ENTIRE
BUILDINGS DESTROYED RIGHT NOW?
>> Reporter: THAT'S A QUESTION
I'VE ASKED MYSELF AND OTHERS
MANY TIMES.
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU CALLS
THEM TERROR TOWERS, WHICH SOUNDS
WONDERFUL BUT THE FACT OF THE
PLAERT
MATTER IS THEY INCLUDE
COMMERCIAL OFFICES, MEDIA
OFFICES, RESIDENTIAL HOMES FOR
ORDINARY CIVILIANS.
U.S. SECRETARY OF STATE ANTHONY
BLINKEN SAYS HE'S NOT BEEN SHOWN
THE EVIDENCE THAT ISRAEL KEEPS
ON TALKING ABOUT THAT IT HAS THE
BUILDING BROUGHT DOWN ON
SATURDAY NIGHT THAT CONTAINS THE
JAZEERA AND ASSOCIATED PRESDS
C
-- PRESS CONTAINED.
WE HAVE SEEN ISRAELI MILITARY
AND SPOKESMEN TALK ABOUT THAT
BUT NONE OF THAT HAS BEEN MADE
PUBLIC.
EVEN IF THERE'S EVIDENCE, I HAVE
SEEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN THE
ISRAELIS HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
TAKE OUT A APARTMENT 3C.
THE LIVING ROOM, NOT THE
KITCHEN.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THEY CAN
TAKE DOWN AN ENTIRE BUILDING IF
THERE'S A FLOOR OR TWO THAT'S
BEEN USED BY HAMAS OR ANY OTHER
MILITANT ORGANIZATION IN GAZA.
>> WE ARE INCREDIBLE TO GET THAT
PERSPECTIVE FROM YOU GIVEN HOW
YOUR EXTENSIVE REPORTING IN THE
REGION.
I WANT TO GET THE VIEW NOW FROM
THE BORDER REGION.
NIC ROBERTSON IS THERE.
NIC, EGYPT WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
BROKERING A TRUCE THE LAST TIME.
WHAT ARE THE MAJOR HURDLES RIGHT
NOW?
>> Reporter: WELL, HAMAS SAYS
THERE ARE TWO HURDLES.
ONE IS THEY HAVE A DEMAND THAT
IF THERE IS A TRUCE AND TOENDS
THE HOSTILITIES THAT ISRAEL ENDS
WHAT THEY DESCRIBE AS
PROVOCATIONS IN JERUSALEM AND
THE OTHER HURDLE IS THAT HAMAS
SAYS THAT ISRAEL IS DEMANDING
THAT HAMAS GOES ON A CEASE-FIRE
FIRST BY THREE HOURS.
THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE TO THEM.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
WE DON'T THE ISRAELI POSITION ON
THIS, ON THOSE TALKS AND
NEGOTIATIONS BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW
IS ISRAEL'S PRIME MINISTER SAID
HE DOESN'T KNEEL IS FEEL THIS I
MOMENT TO END THE CONFLICT.
THEY'RE GOING AFTER HAMAS
TUNNELS WHICH THEY USE TO MOVE
FIGHTERS AROUND THE BATTLEFIELD.
THAT'S WHAT ISRAELI DEFENSE
FORCES SAY AND THIS ARTILLERY
POSITION HAS BEEN FIRING SHELLS
INTO GAZA OVER THE PAST COUPLE
OF HOURS, FRESHLY DELIVERED
ARTILLERY ROUND VSS HAVE BEEN
LOCATED.
THE INDICATIONS ARE FROM HERE
AND THESE ARE ARTILLERY
POSITIONS ARE USED TO TARGET THE
TUNNEL NETWORKS AS WELL.
THE INDICATIONS ARE THERE ARE
STILL TARGETS THAT BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU AND HIS GOVERNMENT
BELIEVE THEY NEED TO HIT WHILE
HAMAS FIRES ROCKETS OUT INTO
ISRAEL RATHER THAN PUT A PAUSE
ON FIGHTING RIGHT NOW.
I THINK OVER THE WEEKEND WITH
E
THE EGYPTIANS REALLY PUTTING
SOME EFFORT INTO GETTING A SESZ
INDICATION.
YOU GET A SENSE THIS COULD PLAY
OUT FOR SOME MORE TIME.
>> IT SEEMS THAT WA